MUSIC VIDEO MICROSCOPE!
>> I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
ONE.
OH, YES.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN I TOOK THIS
PICTURE AT A STOCK PHOTO
CONVENTION.
>> THIS IS A NEW SEGMENT WE ARE
GOING TO DISSECT A CURRENT
MUSIC VIDEO THAT SMELLS WORSE
THAN A DEAD FROG.
NOW, REMEMBER PATO, THAT
ADORABLE RAPPING CAB DRIVER FROM
REBECCA BLACK'S FRIDAY, YOU HAVE
PROBABLY SEEN HIM AND WISHED
HE WOULD BUST SOME OF HIS OWN
RHYMES. YOU ARE IN LUCK. HE'S
GOING SOLO, AND HIS SINGLE HIT
YOUTUBE THIS WEEK ALONG WITH HIS
FRIEND RICHIE, AND THEY EXPLORE
QUESTIONS LIKE, LIKE WHAT WOULD
WOULD THE WORLD LOOK LIKE IF
BATH SALTS WERE LEGAL?
WE WILL GIVE YOU TWO CRAZY
OCCURRENCES AND YOU TELL US
WHICH ACTUALLY HAPPENED DURING
THIS FOUR MINUTE MALARIA DREAM.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO REMIND THE
SONG IS CALLED FACETIME, AND IF
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY IT IS
CALLED FACETIME YOU WILL NEVER
FIND THAT ANSWER.
DO RICHIE AND PATO DOUBLE-TEAM A
MIDDLE-AGED WOMAN USING THEIR
TREE PENISES, OR PATO SLICES HIS
HAND WITH A DAGGER AND RICHIE
DRINKS HIS BLOOD, WHICH IS
BRIGHT PURPLE.
>> IT HAS TO BE TREE PENISES
BECAUSE I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT.
IF IT'S RIGHT, WE GET TO SEE
TREE PENISES.
>> YOU MAY BE IN LUCK. LET'S
SEE.
>> TREE PENIS!
>> OH, MY GOD!? WHAT? WOW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: THE NEXT ONE.
AN ELDERLY MINOTAUR IS CRUCIFIED
AND RESPONDS BY SINGING IN A
BEAUTIFUL FALSETTO, OR A WOMAN
POOPS OUT AN UNCONVINCING CGI
VINE THAT ENTERS RICHIE'S ANUS.
>> WE WILL WIN EITHER WAY.
>> PLEASE SHOW ME ELDERLY
MINOTAUR.
>> WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
>> WHAT? NO!
>> I GET IT, THOUGH, GUYS, WE
ARE ALL ONE.
>> SNAKE LADY TURNS RICHIE AND
PATO INTO FAT OLD MEN
AND THEN PUSHES THEM INTO A
BLACK VORTEX OR PATO GIVES
ANAL BIRTH TO AN ASIAN BABY
WEARING A CROWN.
WELL I'M SEEING A THEME HERE OF
THINGS GOINGS INTO HOLES.
PATO GIVES ANAL BIRTH TO A SWEET
ASAIN BABY.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> I AM REALLY DISAPPOINTED.
>> Chris: WHY?
>> BECAUSE I WANTED TO SEE THE
OTHER ONE.
>> I AM JUST DISAPPOINTED WE
WILL NEVER GET THAT TIME BACK.
IT IS GONE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> I WAS WATCHING THE WHOLE TIME
GOING, WAIT, WAIT THERE IS
STILL A CHANCE.
THERE IS A CHANCE.